i'm sorry i just noticed your thumbs
andy why are your thumbs bandaged oh
these oh
i had a procedure done and they're
healing so they'll be like this for a
little bit
what does that mean procedure well
uh my whole life i've been
self-conscious about
how small my thumbs are you know i mean
compared to other guys
so i finally did something about it and
i got them surgically enlarged
andy i've known you 28 years i never
thought your thumbs were too small
yeah i mean well that's nice of you to
say conan but
i really noticed it the other day when
you and i took that instagram photo
together
look at it look at it hit there see
compared to yours it's tiny
now put them next to each other see like
mine's like a baby's thumb
you know what i hadn't really noticed it
but when i see him side by side
yeah i see it now that you point it out
yeah
and i really think it probably cost me
some hand modeling jobs over the years
yeah probably cost a few hitchhiking
rides see now i can make fun of it but
you can't
i'm sorry that was wrong anyway uh you
got your
thumbs enlarged i don't understand what
does it involve
well uh i got it done at beverly hills
big thumbs and
they actually put out a video so we can
show that
we apply local anesthetic and make an
incision at the base of your thumb
then we snip the tendons and pull the
muscle way out
we insert a bone graft from your rib for
stability
then we inject silicone to fill out the
area
now you have a big thumb wow that's
that's incredible uh when did the
bandages come off
oh gosh uh let me see there's friday
saturday sunday monday
oh you know what today mark can you can
you help me get these bandages off
please
wow they're perfect check out these
monsters look out tight jars
i'm sorry they look disgusting are they
gonna stay that color
oh you know i was worried about that too
but it's perfectly normal here look at
the video
discoloration after the procedure is
normal and
only temporary your thumbs will regain
their natural
color in one to two years beverly hills
big thumbs
thumb things are worth it
congratulations andy you made the right
call they kind of stink
too yeah i can smell that from here oh
yeah
it's kind of like cheese yeah cheese i
guess cheese could puke
yeah cheese could puke and was in the
sun for a long time